I want to jump into a few spoiler
questions and things that you know so
the first is how did you get Michael Bay
to do a cameo in this movie yeah so it
was he was not bad that easy actually
because he was doing six hundred grants
so he was very very busy but for us it
was just you know it was like super
important it was no Maj it was important
you know it was like you're having his
blessing on the movie so we did
everything to get him and eventually had
that one day you know that one moment
that we could get him and for a very
short period because he was doing
post-production and any we wanted to do
a Michael Bay shock with Michael Bay you
know there was like but also he turns
you know and any other actor would have
needed like ten takes to do it right but
he did it what I take it right away he's
the one taker yeah he said we were also
super nervous because you know Michael
bacon we heard that he can scream Oh
drew worked on his movies so they were
all like you know Michael Bay's hardcore
stressed out that he was super stressed
yeah but yeah eventually came to the
city it's like a super nice guy and but
he said one thing to us he said don't
[ __ ] up my baby yeah right so how did
you know the whole time that that was
the scene can you describe what the
scene was and was it always that that
Michael was gonna do or did you have
ideas to put him somewhere else in the
movie yeah there were a couple of places
where we tried to put him but I think
you know one of the producers came up
with the only one y-you know the MCU of
the wedding it could be Michael Bay and
you know it's it's cool to have him and
the two actors you know Willem Martin
they're present as well and also he says
Uncle Mike which for us Michael Bay's oh
my dear Uncle Mike so that was like
perfect
that was like yeah the perfect place to
to have him there and the perfect you
know timing in the movie to have that
that great you know little wink what is
it like walking over to Michael or did
you walk over to Michael and actually
give him direction well Michael was
really awesome nervous he was nervous he
was like did I did I do it good
so yeah you [ __ ] Michael Bay
sorry mistakes with the camera movement
but he was you know after for this
particular shot just to cover he
explained to the steady camera how to do
the shot anything directly he shot a
were like everywhere just yeah Michael
is very like I've seen Michael work and
Michael is Michael he is the boss yeah
do you know what I mean and if you're
working with a lot of his crew so what
is it like I mean you're I'm saying like
just I mean III thank you for sharing
that story like that's just awesome
million cool I mean for us he was just
like watching him actually direct his
own shot in a Michael Bay shot it's like
oh man boy you permit us any file
awesomeness you know we were just like
in our of that moment that this is like
my personal favorite shot of the movie
yeah I hope this shot will be get
studied in film school did you show him
the movie have you says he seen it yet
no he was also doing his movie six
anniversary it was like did at the time
yet but some of his friends saw the
movie yeah and they called him and they
say I gotta admit it's good you know
it's funny because I would imagine he
wants us to be good yeah because this is
his baby yeah but at the same time I'm
sure there's an element that he's like
don't make it too good understand that
completely yeah because this this movie
you know it's no match to his sin amide
so much to the Michael Bay movies of the
90s movies I grew up in so so I think
it's it's gonna be interesting to see
dad because it's it's not a Michael Bay
movie it's it's a am be homage to a
Michael Bay